so good to see you to see you too last
time I saw you was in Hawaii was Jumanji
that's right only bring you to exotic
location yeah I gotta get you out of
Toronto you got you got to come to
Toronto you're come one day right I well
I love Toronto yeah you have to come
down but did you talk to Kevin Hart
about this bromance between you and
Jason did you set him up and kind of
check on him is he okay with
everything's not okay because he's just
jealous by nature that's the problem
with Kevin Hart he's just a jealous man
by nature I try to tell him don't be
jelly look it's just it's love is love
yeah but he doesn't like it but that's
okay that he doesn't like it you know
why because it's gonna help him grow
that's good he needs to grow just a
little bit right
you know leading up to this this is what
I adore about you is that the fact that
you're educating people through this
film all I've been reading about is a
Samoan heritage I've been learning about
the sea Vittal ritual I was but the
lavalava shirtless amen to all of that
but there's a beautiful story line in
this and it got me thinking what does it
mean to you to know that your kids will
know that you educated the world about
their heritage grateful just really
grateful that's what it means to me just
grateful because we it's an opportunity
that we had with ABS and Shaw to
showcase a culture that has been really
underrepresented it's actually never
been represents a big big moment we we
knew the responsibility and I knew of
the opportunity and I wanted to do all I
can and make sure that you know it was
we were well represented as a culture
but also educate the world and also make
sure that if we could somehow tie in
because the world is always at stake in
these movies and the Fast and Furious
movies it descends upon sama but then
also if we could create a reality where
we have to go to war to try and save the
world but we have no guns
and we just have to use these and this
yes and so it was it was really really
beautiful and I'm so happy we did it and
I'll tell you this crazy story because
she's gonna love telling this is that G
my mom was there on set she's great
she's my mom yes she carries around a
photo album with me it's terrible yeah
it's terrible but anyway she was on set
and she fetch it was incredibly moving
for her too as well a lot of Tears so it
was very emotional I mean I look at you
and everything that you've done
over the last few years like have you
had a chance to kind of sit back and
reflect help great life is I'm sinking
I'm so happy you brought that up I mean
I really am
I it's so important that I've realized
this for me but everybody by the way cuz
life moves so fast and I've learned
you've got to take your time
you got to pause you gotta unplug you
you have to look around you have to take
inventory emotional inventory spiritual
inventory what you have your kids your
relationship to job everything and if
not you kind of just lose a little bit
of perspective so to your wonderful
smart question I try to do it as much as
possible but life moves quickly so you
really have to force the pause to happen
and unplug someplace go away 30 minutes
an hour whatever it is so I've been
doing that more and more
you